all right so now we have space jam this
nostalgic trip to toontown
starring looney tunes and basketball's
goat
and this is the sequel to that movie
starring lebron james
jam was space jam a
new legacy generation something like
that space jam 2 so space jam 2 stars
lebron james a sequel
to space jam starring michael jordan
lebron james sun is snatched up by this
ai played by don cheadle so now of
course he has to play basketball to free
him in the movie
they do their best for it to make sense
in terms of its premise
but the first movie did that too and you
know what they say if it walks like a
sequel to space jam talks like a sequel
to space jam
it must be an advertisement for hbo max
which you can sign up for now
which is exactly how this movie feels
early on in this movie i knew
this movie was in trouble during the
setup you have this kid who plays little
kid lebron james
and i was like okay right now i kind of
want this movie to be little kid lebron
james
is the star and he helps out the looney
tunes in a basketball game and that's
how he knows like hey i have a talent
for basketball
and so now we it leads to lebron that we
have i knew that wasn't going to be the
premise
but you can clearly see a better movie
in here
with that because this movie's just
you're bombarded with
references and easter eggs and movie
references and other references
some of it really cracked me up it was
like a really clever snl sketch but then
it just keeps on going with it and it
doesn't stop it's like okay that whole
thing with the references
that's done and over so now we have this
whole other thing with other movie
references
i said that in my loki finale video
where it's like i like references but at
a point when it starts superseding the
actual
movie and the plot and the characters
it's to the movie or show's detriment at
that point not that i'm looking for gold
from space jam 2 the original space jam
nostalgic but you know it's not that
great but it's nostalgically great it
came from a time when movies didn't take
itself too seriously there was still a
purity to it there's a purity in the
plot where the looney tunes are being
invaded and they're like okay well these
little guys and we challenge them to
basketball and they turn into big
monsters so now we need the best of the
best so they get michael jordan the
problem
came to the looney tunes and the looney
tunes sought out help
in space jam 2 is it a new legacy hold
on ah it is a new legacy i was
70 percent as sure so in space jam a new
legacy the problem comes to lebron in
which he has defined help
among all these warner brothers
properties in which that
really opens the floodgates for a lot of
help he's even the smart one who
addresses he's like okay
let's get superman let's get king kong
let's get the iron giant let's get
anyone who would be a good basketball
team and bugs bunny's kind of this
[ __ ] who stonewalls him he's like
no we're gonna play with looney tunes
because pretty sure lebron had it right
like yeah get superman
you can feel like uh yeah my kid's in
trouble and we really need your help
superman
whole computer thing and he'll be like
well it sounds like brainiac is at it
again
you could be like yeah brainiac sure uh
let's go get my son from brainiac
as for the biggest piece of controversy
in this movie which is lola bunny's
character design she has gone from her
original space jam character design
which i classify as we all google image
searched whether we like to admit it or
not to a less provocative
bunny lady character design internet's
not happy about that to that i say
folks those rule 34 artists are gonna
make magic happen regardless you're
worrying about
nothing is fine and while i was thinking
maybe hoping
that the movie was wrapping up it felt
like it was wrapping up i was really
getting the restless leg syndrome i was
like this movie's way too long
it is and i realized i was bored because
i wasn't watching the game i could have
been watching the game
but the entire audience is made up of
warner brothers properties and
characters and it was really distracting
i can't really tell you a lot of
what happened on screen because i was
looking at like oh hey those batman
characters and that's the penguin from
batman and oh look at that
there's pennywise i feel like in one of
the brainstorming sessions in this movie
someone threw out the idea of having
warner brothers
character properties as the audience for
the basketball game then someone else
must have pushed back with yeah but
that'd probably get really distracting
and take people's eye
off the game and they're looking into
the background we don't necessarily want
to do that do we the person who
countered with that
give that person a raise because they
deserve it maybe half the reason it was
distracting was because
they looked like extras and stand-ins
who were just painted up like these
characters
they didn't look like the characters
from the movie it looked like
snl cast members made to look like
characters in a movie which kept that
snl thing going and that's what i can
say about this movie this movie feels
like the longest
most expensive snl sketch i've ever seen
in my entire life some of the references
cracked me up i'm not going to say they
didn't there's one joke in particular
stands
head and shoulders above all other jokes
in this movie the movie went on for way
too long probably felt that way because
i felt like i was watching a
feature-length advertisement i like a
lot of the movies referenced in here but
as for space jamming new legacy i'm not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day
yeah already forgot all right so space
jam a new legacy have you seen it what
did you think about it or at least the
original space jam
is that a nostalgic movie for you do you
have good memories with that movie
what do you think about that whatever
you think about either comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you